la parole est à Madame Catherine de
roche pour le groupe Union pour un
mouvement populaire vous avez la parole
madame la
Présidente merci monsieur le Président
Monsieur le Président Mesdames et
messieurs les ministres mes chers
collègues ma question s'adresse à Madame
la Ministre de des affaires sociales de
la santé et du droit des femmes madame
la ministre depuis des semaines le monde
de la santé est en ébullition en effet
la fin de l'année 2014 et le début 2015
Verron mouvements de grève qui sont
annoncés par les les professions
médicales et qui inquiètent nos
concitoyens vous avez face à vous un
front uni ce qui un fait assez rare pour
pour le souligner un front uni qui
associe les syndicats de médecins qui
associe les médecins généralistes les
médecins spécialistes quel que soit le
leur secteur conventionnel d'activité
qui associe le secteur privé et le
secteur public qui associe des médecins
exerçants en province ou en région
parisienne et je n'oublie pas les
urgentistes ce front uni est assez rare
pour que le Conseil de l'Ordre et que
l'Académie de médecine s'en soit fait
l'écho mais ce n'est pas un mouvement de
GR corporatisme madame le ministre c'est
bien un mouvement d'inquiétude profonde
du monde médical face à certaines
dispositions de la loi de santé publique
inquiétude des syndicats de médecins
face à la généralisation du tiers payant
et à la revalorisation de la
consultation du médecin généraliste
inquiétude de l'hospitalisation privé
quant à ses financements et à une
recentralisation des pouvoirs autour des
ARS inquiétude des chirurgiens des
cliniques des internes des hôpitaux
publics qui sont en grve illimité et qui
s'inquiètent pour leur avenir et si nous
ne pouvons que souscrire un projet de
loi qui en effet remet le patient au
cœur du du parcours de soins qui axe sur
la prévention et qui bien sûr souhait
réduire les inégalités certaines
dispositions de ce texte madame la
ministre risquent de mettre mal notre
système français de santé notre modèle
français de santé qui certes il doit
s'adapter au défi actuel doit continuer
à reposer sur ces deux piliers publics
et privés la grogne est profonde les
crispations sont importantes or le
dialogue semble rompu mais les
professionnels de santé le monde médical
attendent de vous des signaux forts de
confiance comptez-vous les leur donner
merci pour vous répondre la parole
madame laence d'État charge de la
famille des personnes âgées de
l'autonomie vous avez la parole madame
la ministre madame la sénatrice
Catherine de roche je vous remercie
d'abord d'excuser Marie soltouren qui ne
pouvait pas être là cet après-midi le
projet de loi relatif à la santé est
d'abord une loi pour les patients et une
loi contre les inégalités les inégalités
de santé et les inégalités d'accès aux
soins lutter contre les inégalités c'est
d'abord miser sur la prévention parce
qu'il y a ceux qui grâce à leur héritage
social ou culturel grâce à des
conditions de vie plus favorables ont
une hygiène de vie qui les protège de la
maladie et puis il y a ceux qui sont
frappés le plus plus tôt plus souvent et
plus durement alors nous renforçons
éducation et information sanitaire et
nous créons un médecin traitant pour les
enfants lutter contre les inégalités
c'est aussi accorder aux patients un
droit à l'information parce qu'il y a
ceux qui savent s'orienter dans le
système de soins et ceux qui s'y perdent
alors nous créons un numéro de garde
unique pour trouver un professionnel de
santé près de chez soi et à toute heure
et nous reconnaissons aussi dans la loi
le rôle des associations de patients
pour la première fois et valorisons
leurs initiatives sur le terrain nous
créons l'action de groupe en santé
lutter contre les inégalités c'est faire
tomber aussi les barrières financières
parce qu'il y a ceux qui peuvent
consulter leurs médecins sans se poser
de question ceux qui peuvent acquitter
le prix de la consultation et ceux pour
qui la nécessité d'avancer les frais est
un obstacle infranchissable alors nous
mettons en effet en place le tiers
payant de manière progressive dès 2015
pour nos concitoyens qui sont sous le
seuil de pauvreté et ensuite généralisé
en 2017 madame la sénatrice cet objectif
de lutte contre les inégalités est très
largement partagé ou pour le moins
devrait l'être le gouvernement a pour
autant entendu ici ou là des points qui
suscitent des inquiétudes chez les
professionnels il s'agit pour une grande
part de malentendu ou de contevérité que
Marie soltouren entend lever un à un
c'est pourquoi elle reçoit à nouveau les
représentants des médecins libéraux pour
aborder avec eux l'ensemble de ces
points et avancer vous le voyez madame
la sénatrice la volonté du gouvernement
est claire il s'agité d'abord contre les
inégalités pour que notre système de
santé renoue avec sa promesse originelle
être accessible à tous c'est dans ce
sens que nous attentendons avancer en
levant les malentendus et les
inquiétudes mais en gardant le
cap merci